[Music]
what is it you miss the most about your
old life with your wife
what does it mean obviously who is ex I
had such a great we there's so much
funny she's such a great drinking buddy
you know like we would go out drinking
and she's she's so feisty and we were
getting fights with other couples and
I'm yeah yeah we can't do that now yeah
well no she's like I mean she used we
she used to drink all the time and now
when she drinks she's like cranky
because she's pregnant
[Music]
he's you guys love me this is a love
affair he's kidding yeah but when she
would she would in the old days before
she was pregnant and she would drink and
drink and drink and drink and drink yes
what you liked it when I loved it how
bad did it get well like one time we
went to this New Year's Eve party in New
York like seven years ago at The Upright
Citizens Brigade theater they have a New
Year's Eve party which is like
underneath a grocery store
mm-hmm and it's kind of dirty and grimy
but that's the charm of it and uh Jerry
O'Connell and Rebecca romaine Stamos
O'Connell right Rebecca remain famous
O'Connell O'Brien yeah yeah good yeah
yeah they were there and my wife was
like really wasted and she didn't want
to be at that party with me anyway she's
like I don't wanna go to a dirty
basement theater and I was like
understood but we went and and she saw
Rebecca Romijn saying O'Connell O'Brien
there and she went up she went up to her
and she was like you must be a huge
loser if you're here and I'm here
which like I didn't understand it at the
time I still don't like what she
actually meant but Rebecca acted
accordingly and got upset right and
there was like a scuffle a brief scuffle
shuffle well you know they got girls
start you know there was like a lot of
like you know they'll pigeon posturing
yeah there's a lot of like
like don't do that and then then there
was like a little a little bit of
pushing and my wife is small my life's
like five one but Rebecca remains like
seven five yeah and so it looked it
looked like someone was yelling at a
[ __ ] like [ __ ] like it was like it was
like if Kevin Durant was yelling at
Peter Dinklage you know I was like those
are very specific references you have to
like the NBA and Game of Thrones to
understand why no one else was yeah and
and then it's like I picked my wife up
over my shoulder to get her out of there
because it was getting pretty intense
and and she was kind of flooded up for
New Year's Eve and she was wearing a
shirt with no back so I lift her and one
of like one titty pop - how kind of
boobie boobie popped out okay grandpa
oh yeah one boob one memory glam days
and stroking that next to me is very
off-putting
go ahead Kitty and I are listening tell
me about the titty
[Applause]